we just had this trip that's very much
on our minds to Mexico and we were
trying in our own way to bring some
positivity to the situation I know that
you are not of Mexican lineage but you
are very outspoken about immigration and
how immigrants should be perceived
absolutely I mean I am were you front
where's your family from Cuban
Venezuelan so from my Cuban side of the
family my grandparents came over and
flee from a communist regime right so
when they came here they they they did
the hardest jobs they could find my
grandmother worked on solely putting the
needles in the record players and told
that crashed and then there were no more
record players and after that she worked
in a textile factory and she you know
helped make the wool for your clothes
and then my grandfather he laid down the
gravel for most of the streets in Miami
so he used to just drive me around and
say help lay down this street and it's
it's a city where I grew up so it meant
a lot to me that immigrants come here to
do our hard jobs and we need to
appreciate them and honor them for
making this country better yeah
[Applause]
you